שיטת הדיאגונליזציה הקוונטית מבוססת הדגימה, או SQD בקיצור, היא אלגוריתם היברידי קוונטי-קלאסי כמו Krylov
דיאגונליזציה קוונטית KQD, כמו VQE ורבים אחרים. בשימוש באלגוריתמים היברידיים
כאלה, כדאי לחשוב איפה כל אלגוריתם מנצל חישוב קוונטי וקלאסי. נזכיר ש-VQE יוצר מצבים על circuit
קוונטי באמצעות פרמטרים שעברו אופטימיזציה קלאסית. במקרה הזה, המצב עצמו נמצא על מחשב קוונטי. אבל
השגת מצב המטרה היא תהליך שמשלב גם חישוב קלאסי וגם קוונטי.
ערך התוחלת של האופרטור מחושב באמצעות מדידות קוונטיות.
אבל גם שילוב קלאסי של איברים נדרש.
לעומת זאת, SQD משתמש במחשב קוונטי כדי לייצר תת-מרחב שימושי שעליו אפשר להטיל את ההמילטוניאן או אופרטור אחר.
ההמילטוניאן עובר דיאגונליזציה קלאסית לחלוטין כדי למצוא את מצב המטרה. נניח שיש לנו
בעיה שמעניינת את המדע או התעשייה שאפשר לנסח כבעיית ערכים עצמיים על מטריצה של n שורות ו-
n עמודות. נניח בנוסף ש-n גדול מספיק כך שדיאגונליזציה קלאסית מדויקת לא אופציה.
ברור שיהיה יתרון לצמצם את מימדי המטריצה שלנו תוך שמירה על כל המאפיינים הרלוונטיים של מצב היסוד. אכן, זו
המטרה של הרבה גישות קירוב לפתרון ערכים עצמיים, כולל שיטות Krylov קלאסיות. בואו נניח שאנחנו יודעים מספיק על הבעיה שלנו כדי לעשות
ניחוש סביר לגבי צורת מצב היסוד, אבל לא מספיק כדי לפתור את הבעיה ישירות. במקרה
כזה, נוכל לבצע הרבה מדידות של הקירוב הסביר שלנו למצב היסוד המבוקש. התוצאות של
המדידות האלה נותנות לנו תת-מרחב של מצבי בסיס חישובי שמכיל את כל הרכיבים הרלוונטיים של
מצב היסוד שלנו. הטלה על תת-המרחב הזה תיתן מטריצה קטנה יותר שעדיין מכילה את דרגות החופש הרלוונטיות.
תהליך העבודה לזה הוא כדלקמן. מתחילים בבחירת אנזץ טוב.
ליתר דיוק, בוחרים אנזץ שהתמיכה שלו חופפת לזו של מצב המטרה. נדון בדיוק מה
זה אומר. בשלב הבא, מודדים את המצב בבסיס החישובי כמו שעושים עם הפרימיטיב של הדגימה.
אחר כך, משתמשים בתוצאות הדגימה כדי להגדיר תת-מרחב שמכיל את מצב היסוד.
אז מטילים את המטריצה על תת-המרחב הזה. לבסוף, מבצעים דיאגונליזציה קלאסית של המטריצה המוקטנת.
בואו נפרק כל אחד מהשלבים האלה, עם תשומת לב מיוחדת להגדרת תת-המרחב.
בכל תחום החישוב הקוונטי, בחירת אנזץ טוב היא תמיד קריטית. במקרה של SQD, הבחירה שלכם באנזץ
תקבע אילו מצבי בסיס חישובי ניתן למדוד בדגימה.
את מצב היסוד האמיתי אפשר לבטא כסופרפוזיציה של תת-קבוצה מסוימת של מצבי בסיס חישובי. תת-הקבוצה הזו
נקראת התמיכה של מצב היסוד. כדי לקבל הערכה טובה של מצב היסוד ושל האנרגיה שלו, האנזץ
חייב שתהיה לו הטלה שונה מאפס על מצבי הבסיס החישובי שבתמיכה של מצב היסוד.
הדיאגרמה הזו מייצגת את המרחב שנפרש על ידי כל המצבים האפשריים על מספר ה-qubit-ים שבשימוש. אנחנו רוצים
אנזץ עם תמיכה שמכילה את התמיכה של מצב היסוד האמיתי.
נתבונן בדוגמה קטנה מאוד של מערכת עם מצב יסוד של s ground הוא 8 כפול
המצב 1 0 0 ועוד 6 כפול המצב 001.
לזה יש תמיכה שמורכבת משני הוקטורים 1 0 0 ו-0 1. נגיד שהאנזץ הוא מהצורה אנזץ 1 הוא A כפול
המצב 1 0 0 ועוד B כפול המצב 0 1 0 ועוד C כפול המצב 001. כך
שהתמיכה שלו היא קבוצה של שלושה וקטורים 1 0 0, 1 0 ו-0 0 1 - קבוצה על של
התמיכה של מצב היסוד. זה אנזץ טוב.
עכשיו תדמיינו שבמקום זה בחרנו אנזץ מהצורה אנזץ 2 הוא a כפול
המצב 1 1 0 ועוד b כפול המצב 011.
לזה יש תמיכה שמורכבת משני הוקטורים 1 1 0 ו-011 שאין לה חפיפה עם התמיכה של מצב
היסוד. זה אנזץ גרוע.
שימו לב שאנחנו לא בהכרח דורשים שהאנזץ יהיה קירוב טוב של מצב היסוד. לאנזץ יכולה
להיות תמיכה הרבה יותר גדולה או שהמקדמים יכולים להיות מאוד שונים באנזץ ובמצב היסוד האמיתי ועדיין לעבוד טוב.
בשלב הזה, השתמשנו באנזץ מוצדק כדי לגרום למחשב הקוונטי לאמץ מצב דומה למצב
המטרה שלנו. מוצג כאן אנזץ ה-unitary coupled cluster או UCJ שמאוד שימושי בכימיה קוונטית.
עכשיו אנחנו רוצים למדוד את מצב המערכת ולקבל מחרוזות ביטים שמתארות את המצב הקרוס של כל
qubit. נזכיר שהערכת המילטוניאן כמו ב-VQE דורשת הרבה מדידות קוונטיות. זה בחלקו כדי
לצמצם אי-ודאות ובחלקו בגלל מספר הקבוצות של פאולי מתחלפים שמרכיבים את ההמילטוניאן.
בשיטות דגימה, עדיין צריך הרבה מדידות, אבל הסיבות שונות. עכשיו, צריך הרבה מדידות כדי לדגום ביעילות את
מצבי הבסיס החישובי הרבים שמעורבים במצבים קוונטיים עם שזירה גבוהה. ב-SQD, מחרוזות הביטים שנדגמו מתאימות
לקונפיגורציות של המערכת המדומה. אם המערכת הנחקרת כפופה לאילוצים מוחלטים כמו
חוקי שימור בפיזיקה או כימיה, אז רוב המצבים שנמדדו יהיו תקינים. אבל חלק ממחרוזות
הביטים שנדגמו מתאימות לקונפיגורציות לא תקינות או לא פיזיקליות בגלל רעש ושגיאות. תהליך שנקרא
שחזור קונפיגורציה שואף לזקק את הדגימות הרועשות לקבוצה של קונפיגורציות מדויקות יותר.
התהליך הזה כולל יצירת קונפיגורציות חדשות על ידי הפיכת ביטים בודדים באופן הסתברותי בהתבסס על
תפוסות אורביטל ממוצעות ומספרי חלקיקים ידועים.
הקונפיגורציות המזוקקות משמשות אז כדי לפרוש תת-מרחבים להטלת המילטוניאן ודיאגונליזציה,
ולשפר באופן איטרטיבי את הנאמנות של ייצוג המצב הקוונטי.
בואו נסתכל על דוגמה פשוטה מאוד של שחזור קונפיגורציה כדי להבין את המשמעות שלו. נניח שאנחנו מודדים
מערכת קוונטית עם ארבעה qubit-ים שמייצגים ארבעה אורביטלים מולקולריים ומקבלים את מחרוזות הביטים הבאות מ-
המעבד הקוונטי. כל מחרוזת ביטים מייצגת את תפוסת האורביטל. אחד עבור
תפוס, אפס עבור לא תפוס. Qiskit משתמש בסימון שבו ה-qubit הכי פחות משמעותי נמצא בצד ימין הרחוק.
לדוגמה, 1 0 1 0 מציין שאורביטלים 1 ושלוש תפוסים. המדידות
האלה נבחרו מסיבות פדגוגיות בלבד. התפוסות שנוצרו לא בהכרח תואמות למערכת פיזיקלית. בהקשרים פיזיקליים, לעיתים
קרובות למערכת יש מספר חלקיקים כולל ידוע. ייתכנו גם חוקי שימור נוספים
שאפשר לנצל כדי לקבוע את הפיזיקליות של מצב שנמדד. כדי להישאר קונקרטיים, נניח שהמערכת שלנו
ידועה כבעלת מספר חלקיקים כולל של n=2. זה אומר לנו את מספר האחדות הכולל שצריך להופיע בתווית המצב
שלנו, מה שנקרא אילוץ משקל המינג.
אבל חלק מהקונפיגורציות שנמדדו מפרות את האילוץ הזה. המצב 1 0 1 0 תקין פיזיקלית. אבל המצב 1 1
1 0 מכיל יותר מדי חלקיקים והמצב של כולם אפסים מכיל מעט מדי חלקיקים. אפס
למעשה. ההפרות האלה יכולות לנבוע מרעש במערכת או משגיאות במדידה. אנחנו צריכים דרך לחזור
לקונפיגורציות שהגיוניות פיזיקלית, לפחות בצורה מקורבת.
זה נקרא שחזור קונפיגורציה.
כדי לתקן את הדגימות הרועשות שלנו, אנחנו הופכים ביטים בצורה הסתברותית בקונפיגורציות לא תקינות על סמך
תפוסת אורביטל ממוצעת ממוצעת על פני קונפיגורציות תקינות.
תפוסות אורביטל הן ערכי התוחלת של אופרטור המספר הפועל על כל אורביטל. זה מוערך ו-
מזוקק באופן עצמי-עקבי באמצעות המצבים שנוצרים מ-SQD. בואו נסתכל על אורביטל 2 לדוגמה. בשתיים מ-
ארבע הקונפיגורציות התקינות, אורביטל 2 היה תפוס. זה נותן לנו תפוסה צפויה של 0.5.
עושים את אותו הדבר לשלושת האורביטלים האחרים. עכשיו חוזרים לקונפיגורציה לא תקינה 1 1 0. אפשר להפוך אחד מ-
הביטים מ-1 לאפס כדי ליצור קונפיגורציה תקינה. אבל איזה ביט צריך להפוך? דרך אחת להחליט היא
באמצעות הסטייה של תפוסת כל אורביטל מהממוצעים שזה עתה חישבנו.
כאן רואים שההפרש הגדול ביותר הוא בתפוסת אורביטל אחד. אז אפשר לצפות שביט אחד צריך
להתהפך מאחד לאפס. כמובן, אורביטל 2 לא רחוק מאחור. ותמיד ייתכן, גם אם לא סביר, ש-
המצב הנמדד הזה הוא תוצאה של מספר שגיאות על אותו מצב.
לבחור רק את הסטייה הגדולה ביותר מהממוצע לכל המצבים הלא תקינים זה לא אופטימלי. במקום זאת, ביטים מתהפכים
בצורה הסתברותית כשההסתברות היא פונקציה של ההפרשים המוצגים כאן. נניח שבמקרה
הזה אנחנו כן משנים את הביט שהכי שונה מהתפוסה הממוצעת. אז 1 1 0 הופך ל-1 1 0 0. היינו עושים את
אותו תהליך לקונפיגורציה הלא תקינה האחרת. נגיד שבמקרה הזה בסוף הופכים ביטים אחד ושלוש.
אחרי תהליך התיקון הזה, יש לנו קבוצה חדשה של קונפיגורציות שעשויה להיראות כך.
בעזרת הקבוצה המזוקקת הזו, אפשר לעדכן את תפוסת האורביטל הממוצעת כדי לשפר את הנאמנות. במקרה שלנו, התפוסות
החדשות הן אלה.
תהליך השחזור האיטרטיבי הזה מבטיח שמדידות רועשות מסוננות לקונפיגורציות בעלות
משמעות פיזיקלית, ומשפר את הדיוק של קירובי מצב עצמי ב-SQD. לתוסף Qiskit של SQD יש כלים
שיהיו מכריעים בתהליך הזה. אם עשינו עבודה טובה בדגימת המצבים בתמיכה של מצב היסוד
האמיתי של המערכת, אז אנחנו צריכים להיות מסוגלים להסתכל רק על החלקים של ההמילטוניאן שפועלים על תת-המרחב הזה
ועדיין לקבל מצב יסוד ואנרגיה טובים. בדוגמה הזעירה שלנו עם 4 qubit-ים, יש בהתחלה 2 בחזקת 4 או 16
מצבים אפשריים של המערכת. באמצעות שילוב של דגימה ושחזור קונפיגורציה, מצמצמים את זה
לשלושה מצבים בתת-המרחב שמעניין אותנו. שלושה מצבים שאנחנו מקווים שמרכיבים את התמיכה של מצב היסוד האמיתי.
עכשיו מטילים את ההמילטוניאן המלא שלנו על תת-המרחב הזה. כלומר, יוצרים מטריצה M מעמודה של וקטורים מתת-
המרחב הנדגם המשוחזר שלנו ומטריצה מקבילה M dagger מהשורות ומכפילים M dagger H M
באופן ציורי. זה אומר לקחת את אלמנטי המטריצה בשורות ובעמודות שמתאימים למצבים בתת-
המרחב הנדגם המשוחזר שלנו. השורות והעמודות המודגשות הן אלה שמתאימות לתת-המרחב שלנו. ו-
התיבות המודגשות יותר במקום שהן חופפות הן האלמנטים שאנחנו שומרים למטריצה המוקטנת החדשה שלנו.
עכשיו שבחרנו את תת-המרחב שמעניין אותנו, אפשר לבצע דיאגונליזציה של המטריצה הזו על מחשב קלאסי
באמצעות פותר סטנדרטי. אם מצב היסוד האמיתי מורכב לחלוטין ממצבים בתת-המרחב שלנו,
הדיאגונליזציה הזו צריכה לתת את מצב היסוד הנכון ואת אנרגיית מצב היסוד. אם יש לנו רק את רוב תמיכת
מצב היסוד, אנחנו עשויים להתקרב. ברגע שקיבלנו את מצב היסוד עבור ההמילטוניאן המוטל הזה, יש לנו מצב מאוד
שימושי שממנו אפשר לחשב את התפוסה הממוצעת של כל אורביטל.
קודם, התפוסות שלנו חושבו ממצבים שדגמנו באמצעות אנזץ שקיווינו שיעזור
לנו להתקרב למצב היסוד. אבל לא הייתה שום ערובה שהתפוסה הממוצעת של כל אורביטל מהדגימה הזו תואמת לתפוסה
במצב האנרגיה הנמוכה ביותר. בואו נחזור אחורה. הייתה לנו דגימה של מצבים חישוביים. השתמשנו בשחזור קונפיגורציה
כדי לתקן כאלה שלא היו תקינים פיזיקלית. אז חישבנו את תפוסת האורביטל הממוצעת באמצעות כולם.
מצב היסוד עשוי לכלול רק חלק מהם. מצב היסוד של ההמילטוניאן המוטל הזה לא בהכרח מצב היסוד
האמיתי של המערכת המקורית שלנו, אבל הוא מצב האנרגיה הנמוכה ביותר שאפשר ליצור מכל סופרפוזיציה של
המצבים המשוחזרים בתת-המרחב שלנו. תפוסת האורביטל של המצב הזה תיתן אנרגיה קטנה או שווה
לאנרגיה של התפוסה שהתקבלה מהמרחב המשוחזר. אז התפוסה הזו היא הערכה טובה יותר של תפוסת
מצב היסוד שלנו. אפשר לחזור על תהליך שחזור הקונפיגורציה עם התפוסה החדשה הזו ולבצע
איטרציות עד שקריטריון ההתכנסות מתקיים. דיאגונליזציה קוונטית מבוססת דגימה מהירה בהשוואה
לאלגוריתמים אחרים לטווח קרוב כמו VQE. היא יותר סקלבילית והיא עמידה בפני רעש ושגיאות בדגימה. היא עדיין
דורשת שנכין אנזץ טוב עם הטלה גדולה על התמיכה של מצב היסוד האמיתי של המערכת שלנו. אם לא יודעים כלום
על מצב היסוד האמיתי שלנו, ייתכן ש-SQD יצטרך לשמש בשילוב עם שיטות אחרות כדי קודם ללמוד על
מצב היסוד ולהתקרב אליו באופן איטרטיבי.
SQD ממלא תפקיד קריטי בסוויטה המתפתחת של אלגוריתמים היברידיים קלאסיים-קוונטיים והוא אחד מ-
המניעים הגדולים ביותר לקראת חישוב קוונטי שימושי.